- [Interviewer] All right, Late the Great.
Late the Great, where'd you grow up?
Where're you from?
- I grew up in Los Angeles.
- [Interviewer] South Central?
- No, various parts,
the West Lake District,
a little bit of downtown
during my childhood.
On the east side for South
Central, just a little bit.
Ya know, I bounced around a lot.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
how was your childhood?
You have both parents?
- Had both my parents until
my father went to prison
when I was age 10 years old.
- [Interviewer] So, how was
your childhood after that?
- Me and my mother ended up
on skid row in Los Angeles
and I started go in and
out of Juvenile Hall
and eventually the
California Youth Authority
for a robbery, just five years
and got out when I was
just about 20 years old.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you go from there?
- Got out, went in as a
boy, came out as a man
and the world was new to me.
I grew up, ya know, irregularly,
because of Y E stretch
and I ended up goin' to New
York to see a different world.
Try something different.
- [Interviewer] What'd
you see in New York?
- It was really fast.
It was foreign to me.
It was downtown Los Angeles, times five.
I didn't have no source of income.
I wasn't technically a runaway,
'cause I was already adult
but I was equivalent to a runaway
because I had adolescent frame of mind
and I was trying to find my way
and I ended up familiarizing
myself with the pimping culture
- [Interviewer] So you had somebody
that kinda took you under their wing
and showed you the way?
- Well, not really.
I was in Hunt's Point, area of South Bronx
and I started hanging
out with pimps and stuff
and they was encouraging me
to bring a girl out there.
They liked my swag.
They liked my West Coast swag
and I had a girl choose me outta nowhere.
As far as she wanted a boyfriend figure.
She'd had pimps before
but she know I vulnerable
and green to the game so she
wanted a boyfriend figure
and told me if I allowed her to be with me
under circumstances of
her being a prostitute
that the money would be for the both of us
and I took her up on her offer
'cause I needed the money
without intending on
pursuing a career as a pimp
and it kinda started from there.
- [Interviewer] So you started out with,
tell me about the first girl that you had.
- That was the one right there.
She was a black girl, she
was a tad bit younger than me
and it didn't last too long
because what she was really wanting
was trying to see the factors
that she wished she had
seen in seasoned pimps
and kinda manipulated me into giving her
to the boyfriend attention
that she would've
got from them guys
but ya know, she wasn't being spoiled
with that from seasoned pimps
so she caught somebody green, vulnerable
and ya know, got what she
wanted outta me, ya know.
And that was about it
but I stepped my foot in the water.
I got a taste of it.
I liked that fast, easy money so...
- [Interviewer] Where'd you go from there?
- I went on ahead and tried to keep going
with getting as many girls as I could
under the circumstances of
working under my employee
and, but my career didn't
go full fledge then.
This was 1999, my career
didn't go full fledge then.
I came back to Los Angeles
and was selling drugs
and stuff like that
but I was in acceptance
of having a prostitute working for me
when opportunity presented itself
but it wasn't a priority to get one.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
you got more into the game
at what point?
- I would say 2002 on Hollywood on Sunset.
Ya know, I saw guys my
age, in my age bracket,
couple years younger even,
driving nice cars, having things.
Having three or four girls, at the least
and I was like, wow, ya know...
Ya know, it made me, it motivated me.
It saying wow these guys can do it.
Ya know, I want in.
I was playing with the game.
I wanted in.
- [Interviewer] Have you
done prison time for this?
- Yes, I have, on two different occasions.
- [Interviewer] The penalties
are much harsher now
than they used to be right?
- The penalties, if the the
human trafficking enhancement
is involved here in
California, it's more harsh
but ya know, that's if the
girl says she worked for a pimp
under fear, force, threat, duress,
threat, intimidation, coercion
ya know, then it's, that
aggravates all the charges.
If it happens to be a minor,
under the human trafficking statue
with the factors I just mentioned,
the aggravated factors
that carry 15 years to life
but just a regular pimping
charge, here in California,
carries six years max.
That's just for being convicted
of living off the earnings
and proceeds of a prostitute.
- [Interviewer] Sixty?
- No, six years.
- [Interviewer] Oh, six years.
- It's three years is low term,
four years is mid term.
Six years is the high term.
- [Interviewer] So how
many girls do you have now?
- Well, based on this
is a public interview,
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- I would rather not...
- [Interviewer] Yeah, understood.
- [Interviewer] Just
don't even answer that.
If you had girls, what sexes would they...
I mean, what races would they be?
- I prefer Hispanic and white
women, over black women.
Sometimes I except a black woman
but her mental capacity
and her beauty factors
have to be equivalent to that
of a Latino or white woman.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of money do they bring in?
- It depends on where they're working,
what method they're using
to catch their dates.
Ya know, it depends on
what kind of woman it is.
What caliber of a woman it is.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Ya know, I can't take a woman
that doesn't do no drugs at all
and work her in a drug infested area
because the clients are
gonna be offering less money
and it's gonna be insulting
to her and I both.
But I can't take a girl
that's strung out on drugs
and try to put her out
there with the girls
that ain't on drugs, that's
getting approximately
80 to 100 dollars a day
and expect her to keep up with that
because, ya know, drugs is their primary
and a pimp and having a manager
while their doing what their
doing is their secondary.
So if a girl that's on
hardcore controlled substance
goes out there, makes a
120 dollars in one date,
she's gonna get lazy and want to come home
and elaborate on how she made
that much in one whopping.
Think it's really something.
To her as a drug addict and
want to get high and waste time
to where as to me, it's nothing.
So, the amount they make, as I said,
depends on where they work at,
what their personal factors are
as far as drug usage or not
and what method is being used
for them to get their dates.
- [Interviewer] And they
give you 100 percent
of their money?
- If they live with me,
they put 100 percent in my hand to manage
but it's not giving to me,
as though it's a donation
and they're not living off it.
I'm more likely to count it for them.
- [Interviewer] And they
get protection from you
or something...
- They get protection.
They get inspiration and motivation.
They get guidance.
Ya know, the security
factors, for the most part,
come in play through the
instructions that I give them
to not get themself
into certain situations.
Ya know, if a person
has more than one girl,
ya know, he can't be, he can't
split himself in fractions
and be there physically
to protect each one.
But if she takes heed, to
what a pimp tells her to do
then she's not gonna find
herself often times in situations
where she's gonna be
in the face of danger.
So that's where the protection
comes in, right there.
However, tricks and clients
are still unpredictable.
It could be the coolest
guy that she screens out
and he'll still, outta
nowhere, unexpectedly
do some weirdo stuff once
their out in traffic.
It happens, that's inevitable.
- [Interviewer] And your
style, I mean, I've learned
that there are many
different types of pimps.
Some are...
ladies men and some are using
intimidation or force, there's
so many different styles.
What would you say your style is?
- I would say my style has
a lot of diversity to it
and I say that because I apply
whichever variation of styles I may have
depending on what kind of woman it is.
Ya know, if she's a knucklehead,
who's not gonna respect a pimp
or respect any man figure
in any kind of partnership
or relationship she's
in, she's a knucklehead
then there's gonna be a lot of hostility
during our partnership
and ya know, it might lead to things
that hostility inevitably induces.
However if she's a smooth chick
then all the gentleman
will come out in me.
So I apply the factors
of my characteristics
toward the woman
according to her behavior.
- [Interviewer] Are some of the girls
taking advantage of their johns?
Getting their wallets,
getting their phones,
getting their jewelry, whatever?
- Most definitely,
because a lot of the women
if ya know, they settle
for that line of business,
that trade
but sometimes in the back of their mind
or on the forefront they'll express
that they don't enjoy what they're doing.
So it's like a compromise.
It's an ambivalence.
They enjoy for the fast proceeds, ya know.
Then they hate it based
on the downside of things
they have to go through
but as far as alternative
sources of income,
alternative way of gaining
the proceeds from a trick
other than flat backing or
giving blow jobs and stuff
if they see an opportunity
for it, they go for it
and they don't feel sorry for them
because he shouldn't been
out there buying pussy anyway
because one classic universal
factor in that matter is
why should I feel sorry for him
when he's doing something
that he doesn't want
his daughter out here doing
or he doesn't want his wife out here doing
but I'm out here doing
it and he's all for it.
So it's kinda hard to
be sympathetic for him
when he becomes a victim to
getting his pocket clipped.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have sex with your girls?
- It all depends on the kind of girl.
Pimps, or myself included,
have had sex with girls
under my employee
but there's girls that, ya know,
it's kinda a business
understanding from the jump,
it's strictly a business relationship.
They don't want to have sex with they pimp
because they don't want
emotions to get involved
or misconstrue it for a
boyfriend/girlfriend relationship
where it will interfere with
the business aspect of it.
Cause you know, women by nature,
when they have sex with a man
they're thinking he's already been paid
because they're aware that every man
does enjoy busting a nut.
To where as a pimp has to
make sure, strategically,
that there's no confusion
and no misunderstanding
that business is one thing
and pleasure's another
and the girl has to
understand the difference
between a slick and a trick
and if a pimp has too
much sex with his girls
and won't save some for the tricks
that gonna run her off eventually.
So ya know, the lady
can't have no impression
that ya know, he's somewhat
equivalent to a trick
because he wants to
get in my pants all day
so I have to go out and
work for him, quote/unquote.
I have to go out and work for him
and then come back and
have sex with him too.
That's kinda a turnoff.
- [Interviewer] What
personality trait do you possess
that helps you do this?
Makes you a good pimp.
- Well, I know how to speak
and articulate valid points.
Rational points.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Good management skills.
Ya know, if a girl makes enough money,
whatever it is, that's her
maintenance consists of,
that's, I'm gonna make
sure she always has that.
- [Interviewer] What qualities
do you look for in a girl?
- Number one, competent.
More than anything else,
even more than looks.
I look for competence
because communication means everything
and only a competent person
can communicate good.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen,
in your years of doing this?
- Wow, there's so many of them.
I'm trying to think which one I can share.
You mean craziest thing
as far as that line of business, right?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, exactly.
- Craziest thing I seen
that line of business
one time in Hollywood,
a girl had got almost kidnapped by a john.
It wasn't a girl of mine.
She had almost got kidnapped by a john
and so she was naked in his car
and she jumped out naked
while she could, okay
and she was running down the street naked
and then got hit by a car.
- [Interviewer] Ooof.
- On Sunset Boulevard
back in the early 2000's.
That's one of the
craziest things I've seen.
- [Interviewer] That's pretty bad.
What are you proudest of in your life?
Do you have kids?
- As a matter of fact, I do.
- [Interviewer] And do you raise them?
- No, I have a son up
in another state, okay
and I just met him for
the first time recently.
His mother was once upon
a time under my employee.
He's a real good kid.
Ya know, has good manners and stuff.
I think he inherited all
of my good genes, okay.
All my good personality traits
and ya just met him for the first time.
Man, it was a good feeling.
- [Interviewer] What are you proudest of?
- Well, let's see.
I'm proud of so many things.
Hold on a minute.
I believe I'm proud of my intelligence.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's
more important to you,
love or money?
- Well, I don't believe
there's a such thing as love.
I believe there's a such thing as respect.
I would rather somebody
respect me than love me
because love is just a word
that's used in substitute
of expressing some kind of endearment,
feelings of endearment towards somebody.
Whereas respect is
often demonstrated, okay
and in money,
money...
money is a coupon to survival.
Without it, ya know, you ain't shit.
So I cherish respect
and money both the same.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Late the Great, thank you so
much for sharing your story
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- Your very welcome.
- [Interviewer] Thank you, man.